[Music]
god damn it it's so [ __ ] late again
and I haven't recorded a video today
professional youtuber everyone I've been
doing YouTube for six years I know what
I know how to make videos shut the [ __ ]
up how do I get out of here watch this
[ __ ] oh my god oh my god
[Music]
that was a joke I'm still here what is
PewDiePie and who is he a question that
people seem to want an answer on and I
thought who is better to answer that
question than me I put in PI
do you like pretty pie I wake up and I
realize I'm PewDiePie and really I just
want to go back to sleep I mean yes yes
I love pr2 pies my favorites
I prefer zero punctuation but that's
just opinion how about I prefer less
shitty mustache have you seen my
mustache ten times but help with online
dates oh oh you need help with online
dates yeah that's what happens when you
watch other channels and not porta potti
she is 352 miles away well good luck
without getting that [ __ ] next time you
watch booty pop you watch [ __ ] my
channel and you get that you you get
that [ __ ] sweet sweet [ __ ] and you
won't be a little [ __ ]
asking for a relationship advice on
Yahoo [ __ ] answers that's right
next time make a better [ __ ] choice I
mean it's not like I found my girl nah
you know what
since I'm since I'm so next I'm gonna
help though he's not a fan of put a pie
wait what the [ __ ] is this no he suck
now he like just play skate 1.23 gay
skate game it's boring game ever
dude that really hurt when you write
these comments there's another person on
the other side of the screen
why are we still you still here
okay he also asked what is media
question mark question mark question
mark question mark question mark media
everywhere I know it's just a sigh and
something this is a person this person
I'm not I didn't set this up to make my
haters look stupid but Jesus [ __ ]
Christ can you be a little bit more
illiterate because I'm pretty sure what
you just said could be said by slapping
your dick on the keyboard so I love when
people they will actually [ __ ]
answered
one use is the main mass of communicate
wait what the [ __ ] is is another one
no his videos are boring / lame who the
[ __ ] like that who the [ __ ] like that
why is everyone so negative about
pitter-pat I don't understand why
everyone hates Felix Kjellberg who is 25
years old because he is a greedy
self-indulgent misogynistic prick with
the fanbase comprised mostly of 10 year
olds if you like Peter Pan that doesn't
immediately mean you're a [ __ ] but most
people can't even take one opinion
against the guy [ __ ] sucks and that's
my opinion and if you're saying anything
else that [ __ ] you it's my opinion like
just because you have an opinion doesn't
mean people can to disagree with you
it's like it's my opinion shut the [ __ ]
up you can have whatever the [ __ ]
opinion you want people can still argue
against you mr. Gabriel Murr which I
will proceed to judge Foley what song is
this I swear to God
okay so this is more like a rap dubstep
[ __ ] kind of song the lyrics littered
out composed of something like dum dum
dum dum dum and / Oh
are you describing yourself I think if
you were to play it on the piano
it'd be more like d e f g f ec e d
around four times well congratulations
you're the [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] spray up Eddie I'm so softly my
ten-year-old sister is watching
PewDiePie my sister her best friends are
sleeping over tonight
they are sat across from me on the
laptop with earphones in a minaret ago I
heard my sister's friend say have you
seen the fist bump it's got three thick
fingers on the top then I heard a voice
that sounded like PewDiePie coming from
but it sounds like a horror novel in a
weird way from the earphones because my
sister is 10 I don't really think she
should be watching him the kiss of
swearing and sex references I don't I
don't make any sexual I know my parents
wouldn't agree should I tell them leave
it thanks
I'm 49 I like this answer by chance oh
shut up lad don't be a sourpuss leave
your sister and friend alone got them
that should just be the answer to
everything just don't be a sourpuss how
to pity pie hair you guys actually want
oh I see you like my oh now you like my
hair don't dot just don't pity pies mail
address I'm a pro and a MRSA pen I would
like to send Felix mercy a letter about
that there you go I appreciate the
comments it's kind of weird that you
would ask for my address dan is not on
fire or PewDiePie best answer definitely
definitely oh I think you mean
definitely or definitely dance [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's super hard-working oh
I'm not hard-working enough you know and
actually for I'm not funny enough is it
because all I do is my opinion
pity past sucks all he does is scream
make pervert two jokes that emo 11 to 13
year olds girl think
[Music]
you're looking good well here's a pity
pie in a nutshell okay all right oh gee
by 27 other YouTube channels haven't
been making me enough Google Adsense
buddy dar what the [ __ ] computer story
gaming channel but I only have a gaming
channel done right it's me wolves at
Holocaust welcome to the opening of my
new gaming channel it's gonna be wacky
and unique I'm gonna play lots of indie
games that you guys have never seen
before time to play happy wheels yeah I
don't see the pride on't see the problem
you're an awesome video by the way
how come PewDiePie has 40 million
subscribers when there is only 7 million
people on the planet like I someone
actually explain it I think you go it
wrong I like this answer PewDiePie is
God and created aliens and made them
subscribe to his channel or they will be
terminated my friend wants to join my
channel but he copies PewDiePie okay i
have a youtube chanel it doesn't have
any videos yet but I'm working on it
slaying you're slaying I also have a
theme park on the side it doesn't have
any rollercoasters yet but I'm working
on it United States not the President of
the United States yet but trust me I'm
working on vote put-upon
2012 boo this should be interesting how
much dispute if I make a year he earns
an obscene amount of money it really
bothers me that someone just who just
sits behind a computer how do you
explain 4q miss Becca oh you added in it
you added it okay I honestly have no
problem with the guy making a living
playing video games
it didn't sound like that was what you
were saying it's just the amount that he
gets that bothers me
oh I'm sorry so the fact that it that
over four hundred three hundred million
people are watching me every single
month entertaining literally hundreds of
millions of people that if that is not
worth anything for you is this not
quality entertainment one thing that I
would have to bring up is it it seems
like people think that the whole world
is just like a pool like a witching pool
and all the money goes into it and then
there's like a like a person sitting by
it and be like oh you're a doctor
here you go oh oh you're or you're
romanians back in line
oh okay you're uh you're an accountant
there you go
or you're PewDiePie where it's not like
me
earning a great living is taking away
from anyone else but also if you put it
in perspective like put me next to like
a Hollywood star Big Bang Theory they're
making a million dollar per [ __ ]
episode per week that's [ __ ] way more
than I would ever dream about so think
about that it's always like oh well pota
pot i absolutely can't stand pretty pie
the guy will not stop screaming so my
ears like they're going to start
bleeding
okay well miss Chronos I want to say I'm
sorry for making your ears bleed it's
never been my attention if I knew that I
wouldn't have done it I mean come on you
haven't given me god you [ __ ] why do
you watch Petey pie I don't understand
why anyone would like him why are you so
mean why are you guys always so mean on
Yahoo Answers
he's funny to me so of course I watch
his video what the [ __ ] make up your
goddamn mind wasn't UK I can't [ __ ]
uh you know I do get a lot of questions
of people saying like why does Peter
Pike keep making videos because he
clearly doesn't have to anymore and the
answer to that is yes I couldn't stop
but I love doing it it's just it's just
fun alright but and and you you [ __ ]
Yahoo Answers piece of [ __ ] are not
gonna make me stop okay
[ __ ] you and that's just my opinion so
if you have a problem with it then [ __ ]
you it's my opinion
you can't talk against me cuz it's my
opinion and my opinion is that PewDiePie
it's the greatest [ __ ] channel but
anyway that was this video I don't know
if this worked out at all and I
apologize as this video was a bit [ __ ]
but you know sometimes you try and you
best and you don't succeed anyway thank
you guys for watching appreciate it
appreciate it a lot I wouldn't be here
without checked so why don't you check
out another one or another one and I'll
see you tomorrow with another [ __ ]
video cuz I ain't going anywhere baby